[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute
mitmietri Sirin Ihnen allen einen
schönen guten Abend Christian du hast
wieder eine große Portion Fußball
Champions League im Angebot mit Frust
und Freude guten Abend das haben wir
heute unter anderem für Sie vorbereitet
die Nord Stream Sabotage und viele
Fragen neue Spuren führen zu
Spekulationen über die Täter
bundesweite Warnstreiks am Weltfrauentag
in Einrichtungen wo viele Frauen
arbeiten und wenig verdienen
und Spannung in der Champions League
München will am Abend den Einzug ins
Viertelfinale schaffen Dortmund hat das
gestern knapp verpasst
[Musik]
wer ist für die Explosionen an den Nord
Stream Gasleitungen vergangenen
September verantwortlich fest steht es
war ein sabotage-akt nach
Medienberichten soll angeblich eine
pro-ukrainische Gruppe dahinter stecken
die Bundesanwaltschaft bestätigte heute
ein verdächtiges Schiff durchsucht zu
haben dass in den Anschlag verwickelt
sein könnte die Ermittlungen laufen es
gibt viele offene Fragen was bislang
fest steht fast Christina gründgen
zusammen
in der Nacht zum 26 September reißen
Explosionen vier Löcher in die Pipelines
not Stream 1 und Nord Stream 2 zwar sind
die Leitungen zu diesem Zeitpunkt nicht
in Betrieb es befindet sich aber Gas
darin das nun ins meerströmt schnell
sind sich Experten und staatliche
Stellen sicher dass es sich um gezielte
Sabotage handelt der Generalbundesanwalt
leitet Ermittlungen ein ebenso die
Behörden in Dänemark den Niederlanden
Schweden und den USA Ergebnisse werden
nicht veröffentlicht bis jetzt heute
wird bekannt dass deutsche Ermittler ein
Schiff aufgespürt haben mit dem die
Täterin Sprengstoff transportiert haben
könnten es sei vom 18 bis 20 Januar
durchsucht worden bestätigt die
Bundesanwaltschaft gegen die deutsche
Firma die das Schiff vermietet besteht
kein Verdacht
zu den möglichen Tätern oder tatmotiven
heißt es lediglich
belastbare Aussagen hierzu insbesondere
zur Frage einer staatlichen Steuerung
können derzeit nicht getroffen werden
die Ermittlungen dauern an
also die Untersuchungen laufen
Spekulationen nehmen weiter zu Kiew
weist jede Verstrickung in den Fall von
sich Moskau fühlt sich bestätigt Stimmen
der Bundesregierung mahnen zur Vorsicht
und Zurückhaltung ist bestimmte auch die
Möglichkeit dass hier eine falsche Spur
gelegt werde die anderen Zimmermann mit
den aktuellen Entwicklungen und
Reaktionen sehr wenig Fakten jede Menge
Spekulationen und noch mehr Reaktionen
auf bislang unbestätigte Medienberichte
die Debatte um den Krimi auf hoher See
schlägt Wellen eine Motoryacht soll von
einer Firma im Besitz zweier Ukraine
angemietet worden sein mit gefälschten
Pässen soll das sechsköpfige Kommando
sich am 6 september von Rostock über den
Darß auf den Weg zu den Pipelines
gemacht haben ein Hobby Unterfangen war
das nicht so CDU-Außenpolitiker
Kiesewetter
hier ist hochprofessionell agiert worden
mit Sprengstoffen die es nicht ohne
weiteres auf dem Markt verfügbar gibt
hier ist agiert worden in 70 Meter Tiefe
da reicht auch nicht eine Yacht sondern
das müssen mehrere Schiffe gewesen sein
und da waren Profis am Werk die eine
nachrichtendienstliche beziehungsweise
auch eine intensive Spezialausbildung
haben der ukrainische
Verteidigungsminister meint in der
ernsten Angelegenheit Scherzen zu können
für mich ist das eine ziemlich seltsame
Geschichte sie hatten nichts mit uns zu
tun ich denke dass eine offizielle
Untersuchung durch die zuständigen
Behörden alle Details klären wird es
wäre ein gewisses Kompliment an unsere
Spezialeinheiten aber es war nicht
unsere Aktivität
bislang verdächtigte der Westen Russland
die Sabotage durchgeführt zu haben nun
steht im Raum dass sie auf ein
proukrainisches Konto gehen könnte
Moskau Frau lockt bereits
der deutsche Verteidigungsminister lässt
sich auf das Gedankenspiel ein
differenziert aber wir müssen ja
deutlich unterscheiden ob es eine
ukrainische Gruppe war also in
ukrainischen Auftrag gewesen sein könnte
oder eine pro-okrainische ohne Wissen
der Regierung aber ich warne davor
voreilige Schlüssel zu ziehen Boris
Pistorius sagt auch dass das ganze eine
Force Flag Operation gewesen sein könnte
also der Versuch die Tat der Ukraine
anzuhängen wem nützt all das Fragen auch
andere die ganzen Spekulationen nutzen
nur dem Aggressor Russland der versucht
weiter den Westen zu verunsichern und
damit die Unterstützung für die unter
Ukraine zu untergraben beim Krimi auf
hoher See wird also weiterhin nach der
Identität von Tätern und Auftraggebern
gesucht wenigstens aber nach belastbaren
Ermittlungsergebnisse
fragen wir nach bei Christian Selm in
Moskau und unserem Kollegen in der
Ukraine Henna Hebestreit Herner zunächst
zu dir wie werden die Veröffentlichung
zur Pipeline Explosion in der Ukraine
aufgenommen
naja hier ist man bestürzt und weiß
sämtliche Verbindungen zu den Vorgängen
in der Ostsee zurück was der
Verteidigungsminister gesagt hat haben
wir gerade in den Beitrag gesehen und
der präsidentenberater podolak sagte
gestern Abend schon sein amüsante
Verschwörungstheorien über den Einfluss
ukrainischer Stellen man habe mit dem
Missgeschicken wir sagte in der Ostsee
nix zu tun und habe auch überhaupt keine
Erkenntnisse zu pro ukrainischen
sabotagegruppen das Zentrum für
strategische Kommunikation dass die
Regierung hier nahe steht zog sogar die
Einhaltung journalistischer Standards in
Frage und meinte die Berichte seien
Wasser auf die Mühlen der russischen
Propaganda dann weiter nach Moskau zu
Christian Sam wie wird es dort gesehen
wie genau reagiert der kremme
ähnlich wie eine Ukraine hatte der Kreml
auch von Anfang an betont dass man mit
dieser Sabotageaktion hier nicht zu tun
habe viermal beklagt man hier auch immer
wieder öffentlich dass man nicht in die
Ermittlung einbezogen werde das hat
grammelsprecher pescov heute auch wieder
getan ja und zu den neuen
vermittlungsansätzen davon hält man hier
gar nichts man sieht das eher als eine
Art Vernebelungstaktik perskov sagte das
sei eine gut gemacht den Medienkampagne
und von denen abzulenken die für diese
sabbatter Sabotage verantwortlich sind
und die Drahtzieher die hat man hier
schon vor Monaten ausgemacht natürlich
auch ohne Beweise vorzulegen aber aus
Russland russischer Sicht ist klar wer
hier verantwortlich ist für die
Anschläge für die Explosion an der Nord
Stream Pipeline aus russischer Sicht
sind das die Geheimdienste der USA und
Großbritanniens vielen Dank an Christian
nach Moskau und in die Ukraine an einer
vielen Dank
jetzt zum EU Verteidigungsminister
Treffen in Schweden dort geht es um das
so wichtige Thema der
munitionslieferungen an Kiew dafür will
die EU eine Milliarde Euro einplanen für
die Ukraine ist das viel zu wenig mehr
zu den Hintergründen hat jetzt Florian
neu an
es ist ein Duo das heute in Stockholm
den Ton sitzt links der
Verteidigungsminister aus der Ukraine
rechts sein größter Fürsprecher aus der
EU der Minister aus Estland beide
verlangen deutlich mehr Hilfe für die
ukrainische Armee als bisher versprochen
hat nicht genug wir brauchen eine
Millionen tenerie Geschosse das wird 4
Milliarden Euro kosten
wir brauchen Geld und wir brauchen es
schnell
der ukrainischen Armee geht die Munition
aus und Russland verschießt pro Tag
zehnmal so viele Geschosse Europa will
diesen Nachteil ausgleichen doch stellt
statt der geforderten vier erst einmal
nur eine Milliarde Euro in Aussicht
nun das Geld fällt nicht vom Himmel wir
haben die Ressourcen die wir haben und
die sollten wir zunächst nutzen
heute einigen sich die
eu-verteidigungsminister im Grundsatz
künftig will Europa gemeinsam Munition
Einkaufen so wie man zuletzt gemeinsam
Corona Impfstoffe gekauft hatte doch wie
damals gibt es einen Engpass nicht in
erster Linie Geld da irgendwas ist nicht
unter ergreifend die Produktion gerade
wenn die Produktion jetzt hochgefahren
werden könnte was sie nicht unmittelbar
kann dann würde sofort auch bestellt
beziehungsweise abgenommen werden können
Ende des Monats könnten erst der
Aufträge an die Industrie gehen und bis
dahin wird aus den eigenen
Lagerbeständen geliefert was Europa noch
entbehren kann
ja wie entscheidend ist Munition für den
Kriegsverlauf um diese Frage geht es bei
ZDF heute live mit dem Militärexperten
Christian Mölling sowie mit unserem
ukraine-reporter Hannah Hebestreit 19.30
geht es los auf unseren Social Media
Kanälen bzw in unserer App
in der Ukraine der spitzt sich der Kampf
um Bach Mut weiter zu die russischen
Söldner der wagnertruppe melden heute
sie hätten den Ortsteil der Stadt
erobert die Ukraine hofft aber weiterhin
die Russen möglichst lang in
verlustreiche Kämpfe in bachmut zu
verwickeln einer Hebestreit hat mit dem
Kommandeur eines ukrainischen
Spezialkommandos gesprochen
er verrät uns nur seinen Kampfnamen
Commander Kurt RAS durch verlassene
Dörfer es sind Randbezirke der Schlacht
um bachmut eine lebensfeindliche
Schlammwüste rundherum wird täglich
geschossen
maximal zu entkräften und das klappt wir
beobachten dass ihnen die Kräfte
ausgehen und dass sie gerade nicht in
der Lage sind anderswo große Angriffe zu
starten
in den Ruinen hat kurz sein ukrainisches
Spezialkommando gut versteckt sie planen
so hören wir einen Hinterhalt gegen
russische Einheiten
zu seinen Leuten gehört auch seinen
Vater Nicola
ein Commander ist ein Commander aber ein
Vater ist ein Vater zu Hause bin ich der
Vater hier ist der mein Kommandeur
dann unterbricht der Lärm des
vorrückenden Panzers den Vater Sohn
Dialog
gut fährt weiter will so dich dran an
der kontaktlinie zu den Russen lieber in
Bewegung bleiben unterwegs zeigte uns
den Vorrat seine Einheit an Kriegsgerät
das schwierigste ist dass wir jeden Tag
die besten Leute in diesem Krieg
verlieren den die Ukraine nicht
angefangen hat alles andere kann
überwunden werden wenn wir Kameraden
verlieren treibt uns das voran wir haben
ein Ziel wozu ist denn jemand gestorben
wenn wir nicht gewinnen deshalb müssen
wir gewinnen
und so bereiten Sie sich vor auf ihren
nächsten Einsatz an der Front bei
bachmund
in Georgien haben tausende gegen ein
Gesetzesvorhaben zur Einschränkung der
Medienfreiheit protestiert dabei kam es
zu Auseinandersetzungen mit der Polizei
und zu Festnahmen geplant ist Medien als
ausländische Agenten zu registrieren
wenn Sie zu mehr als 20% aus dem Ausland
finanziert werden ein ähnliches Gesetz
gibt es in Russland eigentlich strebt
Georgien an den Beitritt zur EU und zur
NATO an aber die Befürchtung nimmt zu
das Land könne sich Moskau zuwenden
wütende Proteste gegen die Regierung die
gibt es auch in Griechenland seit dem
schweren Zugunglück vor rund einer Woche
ist das Land in einer Art
Ausnahmezustand Ausschreitungen und
Streiks fast jeden Tag so auch heute
hier in Athen 10.000 waren auf den
Straßen der landesweite Fährbetrieb
wurde eingestellt die U-Bahn blieb
geschlossen Krankenhäuser arbeiten nur
reduziert die Demonstranten fordern die
lückenlose Aufklärung des Unglücks bei
dem 57 Menschen starben
in Nordrhein-Westfalen ist die Polizei
mit einer Razzia gegen Kindesmissbrauch
vorgegangen in 27 Städten haben
Ermittler Wohnungen durchsucht und mehr
als 500 Datenträger sichergestellt
verdächtigt werden insgesamt 34 Männer
und eine Frau sie sollen Fotos und
Videos von sexueller Gewalt an Kindern
über Messenger Dienste ausgetauscht
haben
heute ist Weltfrauentag und weil es eben
vor allem Frauen sind die oft mit
niedrigem Gehalt in sozialen Berufen
arbeiten hat wer die den Warnstreik im
öffentlichen Dienst heute ganz bewusst
auf soziale Einrichtungen und Kitas
konzentriert hunderttausende Eltern
standen also mit ihren Kindern vor
verschlossenen Türen in Stuttgart z.B
blieben die meisten der 180 städtischen
Kitas zu in manchen gab es nicht mal
eine Notbetreuung
er soll wehtun ihr Streik sonst ändert
sich nichts findet Erzieherin Tina Zink
und verteilt in Stuttgart Streikgeld
alle städtischen Kitas sind geschlossen
die Betreuung an Schulen dicht
Notbetreuung gibt’s nicht es geht
einfach auch schon ums Geld also eine
Kollegin von mir die sagt durchgelesen
bei Porsche weil da einfach super
bezahlt wird also fand ich schon hart
bundesweit auch hier in Hamburg streiken
zehntausende aus dem sozial und
erziehungsdienst die Forderung von Verdi
10,5% mehr Lohn mindestens 500 €. wir
müssen uns immer weiter einschränken und
müssen aber immer mehr Arbeit machen und
das schaffen wir einfach dann auch nicht
und es wird alles teurer und wenn wir
dann auch noch eng besetzt sind was bei
uns dauert Zustand ist dann kann man
sich das vorstellen wie ein Feuerwerk im
Kopf und ich finde das muss auch bezahlt
werden ganz gezielt soll am
Weltfrauentag die Bezahlung vieler
Frauen im Mittelpunkt stehen
gleichzeitig trifft der Streik viele
berufstätige Mütter wie Katrin
hilgermann sie musste Urlaub nehmen
besparst ihren Sohn im Stuttgarter
Kindermuseum und ringt um Verständnis
ärgert mich schon ja weil letztes Jahr
erst die große streikquelle hatten und
jetzt fängt es wieder an also ich kann
es nachvollziehen das gestreikt wird
aber auf den Rücken der Eltern wird es
ausgetragen ja das verstehe schon dass
die Pflegeberufe die erzieherberufe die
jetzt Sozialberufe im Vordergrund
gestellt werden wer bleibt auch zu Hause
sind halt meistens die Frauen deswegen
bin ich sehr zufrieden und die nächsten
kita-schließungen könnten bald anstehen
sollte die dritte Verhandlungsrunde
scheitern droht wer die mit
unbefristeten Streiks
weltweit haben Frauen diesen 8 März
genutzt um für ihre Rechte auf die
Straße zu gehen ob im afghanischen Kabul
im nigerianischen Lagos oder in Berlin
wo wie in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern
übrigens auch heute Feiertag ist der
Internationale Frauentag hat die
Gleichstellung von Mann und Frau zum
Ziel und um das zu erreichen er muss
auch in Deutschland noch einiges
passieren so sind zum Beispiel Frauen in
Führungspositionen immer noch unter
repräsentiert Katrin Lindner hat eine
Chefin getroffen
Sonnewalde im Süden von Brandenburg
Ricarda Schlieper ist Chefin von 170
Angestellten und sechs Niederlassungen
im Landmaschinenhandel einer Branche die
von Männern dominiert wird ich habe
bisher nur positive Erfahrungen gemacht
dadurch dass hier eben aus der Historie
heraus viele Frauen sowieso schon
gearbeitet haben wesentlich mehr als im
Westen so dass eine Frau in einer
Führungsposition oder überhaupt im
Berufsleben nichts Ungewöhnliches ist
auch ihre Kundin ist Chefin in einem
Brandenburger Agrarbetrieb als
alleinerziehende Mutter zweier Kinder
ich denke Frauen brauchen ein bisschen
mehr Mut und ein bisschen mehr
Selbstbewusstsein weil können tun es der
Frauenanteil in Führungspositionen bei
Unternehmen die im Handelsregister
eingetragen sind liegt bei 24 Prozent
Brandenburg führt die westdeutschen
Bundesländer hängen hinterher an
vorletzter Stelle Baden-Württemberg
schließlich ist Bremen
Frauen brauchen gute Schulen gute
Kindertagesstätten verlässlich
qualitativ einfach klasse sie brauchen
einen Umfeld wo man ihnen kein
schlechtes Gewissen macht und sie
brauchen natürlich auch so eine ja ein
festes Rückgrat sage ich immer
Ricarda Schlieper weiß dass sie das
Familienunternehmen anders führt als
einst ihr Vater Männer sind sehr
leistungsorientiert und Frauen sind
vielleicht auch leistungsorientiert aber
haben anderen Ansatz die Leute
entsprechend mitzunehmen es geht nicht
um das Ergebnis sondern es geht um den
Weg dahin und das Ergebnis kommt dann
ganz automatisch den zwei Chefinnen in
Brandenburg ist klar dass auch in ihrem
Bundesland noch mehr möglich ist
vergangenen Freitag würde eine Studie zu
Missbrauchsfällen im katholischen Bistum
Mainz vorgelegt heute bezog Bischof Kohl
Graf Stellung dazu dabei distanzierte er
sich von seinem Vorgänger dem
Verstorbenen Bischof Kardinal Lehmann
dieser aber einen menschenfreundliches
Gesicht gezeigt sei Missbrauchsopfern
aber mit einer unglaublichen Härte
begegnet kohlgras versprach weitere
Aufklärung
im Kampf gegen den Klimawandel beginnt
Dänemark damit CO2 einzulagern und zwar
unter dem Meeresboden der Nordsee
Kronprinz Frederick gab heute den
Startschuss für das internationale
Projekt
flüssigtes CO2 aus Belgien gelangt jetzt
per Schiff zu einem alten Ölfeld vor
Dänemarks Küste es gilt als das weltweit
erste grenzüberschreitende klimaprojekt
dieser Art
der Winter der war ja gefühlt schon
durch bei uns auf Schnee hätten die
meisten jetzt wohl verzichten können
aber was hilft es in vielen Teilen
Deutschlands kommt der seit gestern
Abend trotzdem wieder vom Himmel und
nicht zu knapp vor allem in höheren
Lagen machte das den Autofahrern auch
heute noch zu schaffen so rutschte im
Hunsrück ein Fahrzeug in einen
entgegenkommenden Kleinbus sechs
Schulkinder und beide Fahrer wurden
verletzt
Enttäuschung und Empörung bei Borussia
Dortmund der BVB ist raus aus der
Fußball Champions League und der Ärger
ist richtig groß anders ist zum einen
die 02 Niederlage im Achtelfinale
Rückspiel beim FC Chelsea die das
sportliche ausbesiegelte und zum anderen
die Wiederholung des Elfmeters gegen
Dortmund die das Weiterkommen der bloß
ermöglichte
der Elfmeter zum 2:0 sorgt auch am Tag
danach noch für Debatten Marius Wolf
bekommt den Ball an die Hand
Schiedsrichter mackeli lässt
weiterlaufen doch der Video
Schiedsrichter greift deines gibt
Strafstoß
die bessere und richtige Entscheidung
war eigentlich wie auf dem Feld denn es
war eine kurze Entfernung der Unterarm
war nur leicht abgewinkelt der hat sich
weggedrehte den Ball nicht gesehen und
der Arm wurde weggesteuert das spricht
für ein unabsichtliches Handspiel und
ein natürliches Bewegungsablauf kein
harvest an dem Pfosten wieder Video
beweist denn mehrere Spieler waren zu
früh im Strafraum das ist gegen die
Regeln allerdings hätte der
videoschiedsrichter in diesem Fall gar
nicht eingreifen dürfen kaiharbeits
trifft dann bei der Wiederholung zwei
unnötige Videobeweise besiegeln das aus
der Dortmunder im Champions League
Achtelfinale
hat noch ein deutscher das Viertelfinale
der Königsklasse erreicht Roger Schmidt
Trainer von Benfica Lissabon durch ein
eindrucksvolles 5 zu 1 gegen den
belgischen Meister FC Brücke
es dürfte das erste mal sein das mit
Roger Schmidt ein Sauerländer aus
Kierspe von den benfica-fans frenetisch
gefeiert wird
wir haben in den wichtigen Momenten
unsere Tore gemacht und stehen verdient
im Viertelfinale
Schmidts Team zeigte sich als vom
Trainer bestens eingestellt spielte die
wehrlosen Belgier an die Wand und tanzte
oftmals durch den Strafraum des Gegners
wie hier der neue portugiesische
Superstar der 21-Jährige gonzaloramush
mit Ende der gestrigen PK hat für
Trainer Roger Schmidt aus dem südlichen
Sauerland nun schon die Vorbereitung
begonnen auf sein erstes Match im
Viertelfinale der Champions League
und alles zu den bisherigen Achtelfinale
Rückspielen in Sportstudio live und 23
Uhr danke wir haben noch die Lottozahlen
von heute und hier sind sie fünf 23 25
26 32 43 und die Superzahl lautet 2
weitere Gewinnzahlen auf lotto.zdf.de
und auf der ZDF Text Seite 557
beim Wetter ist Regen und Schnee
angesagt mehr dazu gleich von ostendärli
das heute journal heute ein bisschen
später um 22:30 Uhr mit Christian
Sievers von uns was ist das schön danke
schönen Abend und bis morgen um 7 Uhr
wenn Sie mögen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter kalte Luft strömt
von Norden nach Deutschland und relativ
milde Luft aus dem Südwesten wo sich
diese Luftmassen treffen ja da schneit
es teilweise und dieser Schnee
verabschiedet sich langsam nach
Nordosten was ihr aber noch sehen ist
ein Sturmtief was uns dann erst am
Freitag erreicht hier draußen auf dem
Atlantik in der Nacht gibt es
Schneefälle nach Norden hin und die
Schneedecke wächst hier an nach Süden in
regnet es teilweise ergiebig und
Gewitter gibt es auch dazu sogar
Sturmböen um Südwest bei tiefsten
Temperaturen von -2 bis -3 Grad die
tiefsten Werte im Norden ja und nach
Südwesten einen plus 9 Grad deutlich
milder in der Südhälfte morgen dann
weiter Regen vor allem in der Mitte der
Schnee verabschiedet sich Richtung
Nordsee lockert es auf und auch ganz im
Süden und das bei höchsten Temperaturen
bis 15 Grad im Südwesten Deutschlands
und teilweise nur zwei Grad im Norden
das Sturmtief kommt dann am Freitag zu
uns und überquert uns einmal bei 2 bis
14 Grad Samstag wird es vorübergehend
kühler und dann wird's wieder nasser ein
schöner Abend